let us take you inside the biggest
heritage
project happening in the uk since 1877
manchester town hall has played host to
many civic meetings
hundreds of weddings hollywood movie
sets and even the historic announcement
of the eu referendum
today it is one of europe's biggest
construction sites since 2018 this
victorian building
has been closed to the public now an
army of over 400 workers
are tasked with replacing and restoring
it to its former glory
the building is wrapped in a scaffold
which
is enabling us to get access to all of
the parts of the building that perhaps
have not had
attention for the best part of that 140
years
given us the opportunity to actually
restore the external stonework facade
the roof will be restored and replaced
and
effectively we're making the building
fit for purpose for the next 140 years
for the first time every inch of this
building is being examined
and after all these years the town
hall's scale and hidden depths
are revealing new secrets many of them
are part of the design
characteristics you can barely see from
ground level
this is manchester town hall like we've
never seen before
and may never see again from the
intricacy
of 140 year old paintings to the fine
detailed stonework but restoring this
iconic building comes with a heavy price
tag
and six years of work it will cost the
council 300 million pounds
but they believe it's worth every single
penny essentially we had one shot at
this
we could have spent less amount of money
and we'd have to come back in 10 years
time to do
more work to it so we wanted to do it in
one go minimise disruption
do the job properly and make sure we
have something that we'll all be proud
of
this establishment means so much to this
city but the grade one listed building
has architectural impact
around the world this is manchester's
crown jewel
it's a real icon of the city but as well
as that it is
nationally and internationally important
it's one of the best victorian gothic
buildings anywhere
manchester town hall needs this major
intervention
without it this renowned building would
fade away
but this is more than just repair and
restoration
it's an opportunity to make this place
accessible for the public
who for the first time will truly be
able to appreciate
one of england's enigmatic buildings in
demand rasheed sky news
manchester